so you really have to see this video of
a fox news host admitting that
conservatives are total and complete
hypocrites and many times I've said if
Obama did this if Hillary did this they
wouldn't just be calling for their
impeachment they'd be calling for their
heads example if Chelsea Clinton had 5%
of the role that Ivanka Trump has had in
the Trump administration if Chelsea was
sitting with other world leaders at the
g20 sitting in for our Secretary of
State FoxNews would be 24/7 demanding
hillary clinton be tarred and feathered
if obama at a press briefing played a
five-minute propaganda video like donald
trump did on monday this week during a
hundred year pandemic they would be
calling for Barack Obama's head and when
Trump has now gone full authoritarian
claiming that he has the absolute
authority to open or close a state at
his demand that governors must do what
he says any supposedly small government
conservative who believes in states
rights or federalism and the
Constitution and says nothing is a
gigantic glaring hypocrite and Brett
Bayer on Fox News called it out some Fox
News people like britt hume have been
sort of just waving off trump's
growingly a growing belligerent
authoritarianism but brett bayer admits
it so good for Brett check this out
brett is asked how do you see the battle
between Trump and governors going in the
future over the over this issue of
opening and closing states here is what
brett bayer says how do you see this
shaping up across the country with the
president with his fiery statements last
night and the governor's trying to pour
a little cool water on it first of all
the Constitution is pretty clear and the
constitutional scholars will say that
this is not the president flicking on
the switch
it's the governors and the local
authorities that have that going forward
I think that there's a POC recei here in
that you know one if President Obama had
said those words that you heard from
President Trump that the the authority
is total with the presidency
you know conservatives heads would have
exploded
across the board to a week ago there was
a lot of coverage of saying why isn't
there a national stay-at-home order the
Constitution is clear Trump doesn't have
the authority the governors have the
authority that's the correct analysis
but Brett goes into the hypocrisy which
is what I like if Obama ever said
something like this right-wingers would
be slamming Obama's authoritarian
one-world government whatever and in
fact many of them were calling Barack
Obama a dictator anyway they're silent
right now and Trump is increasingly you
know the the the the things that Obama
was accused of being Trump increasingly
is and very few people are actually
calling it out so of course you know
disclaimer one moment of truth and
clarity on Fox does not change that they
continue to big-picture be water
carriers for the disinformation of Trump
through the corona virus pandemic but
here's the really scary thing about Fox
News to me if they are successfully able
to spin this presidency into something
that maintains 40 percent support for
Donald Trump they can spin anything to
40% support and what I mean by that is
this is by far the most outrageous
presidency we've had in the modern media
era george w bush was a disaster he was
a war monger i'm not praising george w
bush but george w bush was much more of
a standard of right winger and the
right-wing media playbook for how to
defend a standard right winger is very
well-written there was nothing new there
we know that that will have roughly 40
percent support foxnews has been able to
evolve on the fly and figure out how do
we defend anything donald trump does and
if they can do it with trump and keep
them at 40% support i fear that there is
no president so crazy that fox news
would not be able to help them maintain
40 percent support no matter what they
do no matter what they they say and we
talk about things are much different now
than they were for nixon in the 1970s
maybe if Nixon had Fox News in the 70s
he wouldn't have had to resign maybe if
Trump didn't have something like Fox
News and the entire apparatus that's
around it maybe he would have suffered
more consequences for his harebrained
action so far that's a really scary idea
and what Fox has proven is that they can
reframe almost anything and still keep
40% of the country saying Trump's doing
a good job and that should scare the
hell out of all of us and it's it's
reminiscent of George Orwell's 1984 but
it's also reminiscent of the kind of
manufacturer of consent
outlined in George Orwell's other novel
Animal Farm which I recently reread and
many elements of what is going on
increasingly today with Fox News and
Trump and media coverage and the virus
makes me think of Animal Farm and that's
very very bad so the daily White House
coronavirus press briefings have really
been the stuff of Horrors in a number of
ways we see lies endless lies from Trump
we see delusions from his task force we
see the bullying of the doctors on the
task force into having to be really
careful and sort of walk on eggshells
and be very careful in how they couch
what happened and what needs to happen
for fear of angering Donald Trump we see
Trump never answering the questions of
reporters we're really seeing it all but
yesterday was a true authoritarian
nightmare with Donald Trump furiously
yelling at the room calling most of the
reporters in the room fakes which we'll
get to and there is so much here but it
is all founded in Donald Trump's
incipient narcissistic authoritarianism
and I'm not gonna go in chronological
order here but I'm gonna go sort of in
levels of authoritarian the fight is now
developing over whose authority is it to
reopen the country which is really about
reopening individual states not every
state closed at the same time not every
state fully closed and these were
decisions made by governors of different
sort of levels of common sense and
rationality Donald Trump is claiming
more and more that it is his absolute
authority to open up the country now
funny number one that he says this
because he never closed the country he
much
later than many states had already done
it gave guidelines to states that they
should follow but more importantly it's
not funny at all it's actually scary
because Donald Trump has become
downright dictatorial and that's the
right word in his pronouncements that it
is up to him and him alone and if a
governor doesn't want to open up a state
Trump has the sole authority absolute
sole authority as president to force
them to do it here is Trump escalating
in his authoritarianism and delusions of
dictatorship what you're trying no not
at all let me just a very simple I'm
gonna put it very simply the President
of the United States has the authority
to do what the president has the
authority to do which is very powerful
the president of the United States calls
the shots if we weren't here for the
states you would have had a problem in
this country like you've never seen
before we were here to back them up and
we back and we've more than back them up
we did a job that nobody ever thought
was possible it's a decision for the
President of the United States now with
that being said we're going to work with
the states because it's very important
you have local governments they're
pinpointed it's really you talk about
it's a like a microchip they're
pinpointed we have local government that
hopefully will do a good job and if they
don't do a good job I'd step in so fast
but no they can't do anything without
the approval of the president this runs
directly counter to the Constitution the
law states rights all of the things that
the people supposedly on Trump's side
have been fighting for for hundreds of
years I mean certainly decades in the
modern era of republicanism
here's another specific question from a
reporter and Trump is just not backing
down he wants to be the authoritarian
but he also wants to avoid any
responsibility when things go wrong
nothing is his responsibility but
everything is his sole absolute
authority more and more sounding like
Kim il-sung and Kim jong-il and Kim
jong-un and the like take a look at this
of your authority these of the
governor's just be very specific for
instance if a governor issued a state
home when you say my authority the
president's authority that might because
it's not me this is when somebody's the
president of the United States the
authority is total and that's how it's
got to be total have a couple of bands
of excuse me excuse me you have a couple
you have a couple of bands of Democrat
governors but they will agree to it they
will agree to her but the authority of
the President of the United States
having to do with the subject we're
talking about is total and then check
out CNN's Katelyn Collins here pressing
him about has any governor said they
agree that this is your call take a look
at what Trump says
we're going to write up papers on this
it's not going to be necessary because
the governor's need us one way or the
other
because ultimately it comes with a
federal government that being said we're
getting along very well with the
governor's and I feel very certain that
there won't be a problem he clearly had
enough of Katelyn Collins and these are
good questions does any governor agree
with you on this idea who gave you the
idea that it is your absolute authority
so this is the way it works in a
dictatorship it's not supposed to work
this way in the United States now I can
assure you if Trump says let it rip on
May 1st or even let it rip on May 15th
many governors are not going to say let
it rip California's Gavin Newsom is not
going to say everybody get back out
there sports the entire thing Trump
can't force Boston restaurants to open
in fact I don't even know that our
governor can force Boston restaurants to
open how do you force a private business
to open right Trump can't force kids in
San Francisco to go back to school it's
patently absurd but the really scary
part is the authoritarian nature with
which Trump claims he can control every
governor and every state and every
business it's not even clear governors
have some of the powers Donald Trump is
claiming he has and states that are
already sort of taking taking and
following what Donald Trump is
suggesting he's going to do have already
said we're not listening to Trump we're
listening to our health experts we're
listening to doctors not the president
now this wasn't all Donald Trump also
turned the White House coronavirus press
briefing into a campaign propaganda
event Trump actually stepped aside at
one point and played on televisions
video of governor's saying nice things
about him - I guess prove what a great
job he's been doing this is just a few
seconds of it I won't play it all Mercy
shut down here
in Los Angeles that was directly because
he sent it down here two thousand
medical units came to the state of
California these FMS these these field
medical stations and that's been very
very helpful the president has been
outstanding through all this the vice
president's been outstanding members of
the Cronin virus task force very
responsive we get asked if we could have
New Jersey could have access to a piece
of the beds that are on the US and as
comfort and the president came back
called the shorten few minutes before I
walked in here to say indeed they would
grant that to New Jersey so that's a big
step for us in addition to all the other
capacity this was essentially a campaign
video and reporters realized this might
in a way violate campaign finance rules
asking Donald Trump was that video
produced here at the White House by
administration staff it was done in a
state government employee by people here
at the White House this campaign style
took some clips and they just ran him
for you and then lastly the briefing
started with Anthony foutch he having to
get up there holding his hat
proverbially and saying despite all of
the reports that I said Trump could have
saved lives by closing and acting
earlier everything was done when I asked
everything is found fine pouchy was then
asked the Donald Trump tell you to say
this and here's how fout she reacted
everything I do is voluntarily please
don't even imply that now to me it seems
like a very reasonable question -
Anthony Fucci and voluntary can simply
mean Trump lost his you-know-what behind
the scenes and foul she volunteered to
make a statement in strict terms Trump
might not have told voci
you've got to make a statement today but
Trump can still flip out and make it
clear foul he needs to do something it
struck me as one of those hostage
proof-of-life type videos they're
treating me well and I'm being fed
really the stuff of nightmares and now I
want to dig into one of the specific
elements of that propaganda
a video that Donald Trump played we can
no longer satirize Fox News because they
are beyond satire Fox News is now a
parody of itself down to the last detail
including the host wearing a gigantic
gaudy cross necklace on the eve of
Easter I'm talking about depraved
diabolical and delusional Fox News host
Jeanine Pirro she may this weekend have
hosted the most weaponized single
episode of a fox news program ever we've
got the corona virus pandemic reaching a
fever pitch 2000 Americans a day are
dying we have no idea how to prevent a
second wave in the fall unless we just
keep the shutdown going disinformation
about the virus is spreading faster than
ever and on the eve of Easter judge
Jeanine was able to put a slate of
guests together that puts previous Fox
News propaganda to shame judge Jeanine
wearing again a comically oversized
cross necklace of course it was the day
before Easter invited Donald Trump Trump
propagandist Peter Navarro who's been
spreading endless disinformation about
the virus and Republican congresswoman
Marsha Blackburn a top right-wing bomb
thrower who never came across a lie she
wasn't willing to tell it's not clear if
judge Jeanine was drunk during this
episode she was drunk during an episode
a week or two ago but you almost had to
be drunk for this television to be
tolerable and what is with the gaudy
crosses by the way I just don't
understand that here are some of the
highlights let's dig right into it Trump
talking about reopening the economy
saying it will be based on facts but
also on instinct which is really scary
the Trump seems to have some of the
worst instincts of world leaders in
American presidents here is judge
Jeanine teeing up a softball for Trump
and Trump answering it as if he is the
great thinker that he believes himself
to be when you make that decision I mean
where do you go within you what is it
that you dig deep for to come up with a
decision aside from all of the people
surrounding you well Janine I think it's
going to be the toughest decision that
I've ever made you know I really
hopefully
we'll have to make but it's certainly
the toughest decision that I've ever
made
and I hope that I'm going to make the
right decision I'll be basing it on a
lot of a lot of very smart people a lot
of professionals doctors and business
leaders there are a lot of things that
go into a decision like that and it's
going to be it's going to be based on a
lot of facts and a lot of instinct also
whether we like it or not there is a
certain instinct to it but we have to
get our country back Trump will be
deciding on instinct that's really
really bad and we should be horrified by
that because Trump's instinct was we
would have 15 cases which would quickly
go to zero this would wash away like a
miracle in April not that we would have
tens of thousands of deaths already so
then in comes Trump's economic adviser
Peter Navarro Navarro has been going
around in media recommending medications
for coronavirus he's an economist and a
highly partisan bomb thrower certainly
not qualified to recommend medications
but he goes on Fox News and does exactly
that including even recommendations for
specific doses of medication take a look
and then we went to some additional
cities down line a lot of them read like
NFL franchises you know it's Baltimore
it's Washington it's Houston and also in
addition the Veterans Administration
asks for a million doses we got that to
them and DoD won and Department of
Defense wanted a foul million doses we
got that to them so there's demand out
there and there's a protocol and let me
just say one thing the protocol in the
FDA it's very clear what they're doing
it's a five-day protocol you take a
double dose the first day next four days
a single dose and I think well let's see
what the scientific evidence says of
course they're talking interchangeably
about chloroquine and zithromax
I believe when he says double dose one
day followed by a single doses that's
your typical z-pak which appears not to
work in conjunction with chloroquine and
it can actually cause cardiac issues and
when Peter Navarro says protocol Fox
News viewers will hear that and think
this is something that's been actually
tested for and calibrated for
coronavirus it hasn't typical z-pak is
to 250 milligrams tablets on day 1
followed by 1 tablet on days 2 to 5 for
use as an antibiotic to treat bacterial
infections when Peter Navarro says this
is the protocol people will hear it and
they'll think that's the protocol for
coronavirus which of course it is not
and in fact we have yet another preprint
of a peer-reviewed study which says that
short-term chloroquine treatment is safe
when you add as if throw Meissen it can
cause heart failure and cardiovascular
mortality that is also separate from
whether it even works on kovat 19 and
that data remains unclear and then we go
to congresswoman Marsha Blackburn using
language that to the average Fox News
viewer will imply China sent the virus
possibly as a bio weapon one of the
things I think should happen with the UN
Human Rights Council and the wh oh my
goodness here we have China being
protected by the WTO and then they're
wanting to have this seat on the UN
Human Rights Council maybe it's time to
review the funding that we send to them
maybe it is time to send that message is
that what China did listen China is not
our friend they are our enemy they have
been ripping us off taking our jobs they
have been sending us this virus this
year they've been stealing our
intellectual property and we need to
realize they are not our friend they are
part of the new axis of evil you've got
North Korea and China and Iran and
Russia and judge these are not people
who wish us well so a few things there
and of course the ignorance is stunning
to the average fox news viewer when you
say China sent us the virus it's going
to sound to them like this was a bio
weapon number two Blackburn has this
incredibly simplistic understanding of
foreign policy with her whole
as our enemy and they are aligned with
North Korea there is no doubt and I've
talked about it the Russia China North
Korea situation is one of concern but
the thinking she outlines here in
relation to the virus okay so if we call
China the enemy then what what about
Trump's laughable handling of the virus
so if we call China the enemy then where
do we get on our caseload it was so
bizarre that even judge Jeanine seems
confused by it at one point she also may
have been drinking we just don't know
there's also been a resurgence in the
era of coronavirus with Fox News just
carrying water for Donald Trump you
might remember that over the few months
before the virus we were actually saying
you know Fox occasionally will do
something other than merely parroting
Trump's talking points and repeating
them rare but it happened
Fox News is fully back on board with
Trump now it's very dangerous it's
putting people's lives in danger on a
day to day basis and Judge Janine's show
on Saturday night one of the worst that
I've seen and it is now beyond parody
you can't parody it because the parody
is not as crazy as what is actually
taking place on Fox News there are two
Republican Senate races for 2020 that
we've been paying very close attention
to and in both of those races Republican
incumbents are in bigger and bigger
trouble every single week and it is
delightful views it's there's so much
bad news going around right now um bad
economic news bad health news bad news
about you know the laughable nature of
American leadership global the globe the
presidency seen as a global
laughingstock around the world this is
good news I'm talking about Arizona and
Maine I'll tell you about both of them
starting with Arizona in Arizona Martha
McSally is the junior senator
she has never been elected she was
appointed to serve out the remainder of
the late Republican Senator John
McCain's seat she's horrible I mean
truly horrible she now wants to be
elected for a full term she's running
against or running against her rather is
astronaut Mark Kelly Mark Kelly is the
brother of astronaut scott kelly Scott's
been a guest on this Pro
very interesting conversation mark Kelly
is also the husband of former Democratic
congresswoman Gabby Giffords who was
tragically shot years ago you may
remember the story and Mark Kelly would
be a tremendously good replacement for
Martha McSally and mcsalley isn't doing
well and I take great pleasure in that
in the latest poll mark Kelly is ahead
of martha mcsalley by nine points this
is huge it's hugely important for the
20/20 balance of Senate power which
we've been talking about because if
Democrats are going to take over control
of the Senate in November and it's a
very uphill battle winning this seat
back is essentially a necessity then we
go to the state of Maine in Maine we
have our old friend the perennial II
disappointed Republican senator Susan
Collins she has a serious opponent and
that opponent is Democrat Sarah
Gideon Susan Collins was first elected
in 1996 she's had pretty easy
re-election every six years in 2002 in
2008 and in 2014 and she is sort of
known for this is not a great thing to
be known for but she's known for acting
like she might take a stand against her
own party against the Republican Party
but then in the end she always falls in
line you might remember that she was
very disappointed with Brett Kavanaugh
but then voted to confirm him to the
Supreme Court she was very disappointed
with Donald Trump's actions with Ukraine
but voted to acquit him in Trump's
impeachment trial months ago even though
it feels like that was years ago
so it is very much long overdue for
Susan Collins to go bye-bye
Sarah Gideon is trying the latest poll
is old now it's from March but it has
Gideon four points ahead very tight but
heading into her last reelection Susan
Collins had pretty high approval ratings
as high as 69% in 2014 Susan Collins
latest approval rating is 37% okay Susan
Collins was reelected in 2014 with a 69
percent approval rating her approval
rating is now 39% this is very bad news
for Susan Collins it's very good news
for Sarah Gideon but both of these races
races are going to be fight so we can't
take anything for granted the reason I'm
telling you this is not so we can all
sit back and say hey we've got two of
these that we're going to take over why
I'm telling you this is to get you
involved as you think about phone
banking if we remain stuck at home for
the foreseeable future these are two
great races where you could get involved
now I know some of you are going to
write to me and you're going to say
David you centrist chill
neither Sarah Gideon nor Mark Kelly are
uber progressive Bernie Sanders types
that's true but we're talking about
removing some really toxic Republicans
here we should all be fighting hard for
that neither Mark Kelly nor Sarah Gideon
are as left as Bernie Sanders but they
are orders of magnitude better than what
we have there right now and it's going
to be either mcsalley or Kelly right
that's it it's either going to be Susan
Collins or Sarah Gideon those are the
choices and defeating these two would be
plus two for Democrats in the Senate
we're going to lose Alabama right now
former senator and former attorney
general Jeff Sessions is running against
doug jones remember doug jones won
against in a special election against a
serial accused sex assault or a predator
i don't know what word you want to apply
to him and now jeff sessions wants his
seat back jeff sessions is winning by 13
in the latest polls we will almost
certainly lose that seat so we need
these two just to get plus one very
important consider phone banking there
we'll talk about other important races
upcoming make sure you're following me
on Twitter at des Pakman let me know how
the quarantine is going for you or if
you've unilaterally decided to end your
quarantine I would want to hear that as
well i'm deepak minh on twitter quick
break back after this laura ingram is
just furious that more people haven't
died from corona virus and we knew that
this would start happening I just didn't
think it would happen so quickly this is
a version of what i called the
anti-vaxxer conundrum I'm not saying
Laura Ingraham is an anti-vaxxer but
this is the anti-vaxxer conundrum and
falling for it
or deliberately perpetuating it you know
depends on your view but this is what
laura ingraham is doing on her show she
is putting out this fury this anger that
in the end fewer people are going to die
from coronavirus then the number that
might have died had we not taken it
seriously let's watch the clip and then
I'll explain what I mean by the
anti-vaxxer conundrum and by the way
another cost of these lame panic
inducing models it looks like we really
didn't need the USS mercy or the USS
comfort in New York or Los Angeles
Americans should be furious about this
of course the men the women in these
ships are doing their valid patriotic
duty
they're amazing the commander's amazing
but this is a lot of money that we're
spending on a response that was based
again on faulty numbers now long before
the government figured out that these
fancy covet 19 models were wrong my own
little team little band of medical
advisors and a few statisticians they're
a lot smarter than I am insisted that
they had also crunched the numbers and
this was weeks ago they were making
decisions the people in charge based on
what my team said were wildly incorrect
assumptions and ultimately incomplete
data so there is a ton here the whole
point of a model is what would happen if
we don't change what we're doing right
now so the numbers aren't faulty it's
that we control the outcome by our
actions you would think someone who
subscribes to the idea of personal
responsibility would understand our
actions determine our future so when the
models said before we shut anything down
based on the contagion rate and the
death rate and viral spread this is
pointing to one point five to two point
two million people could die in the
United States or maybe the number is
300,000 to 500,000 depending on which
model you looked at we then did stuff
right like shutting things down
reducing contagion reducing spread
which then modifies the curve changes
the trajectory and we have new data with
which we make a new set of projections
and of course the projected deaths
decrease the more stuff that we do so
people have been sitting at home for a
month many of us five weeks the ones of
us that took this seriously right away
and had a responsible governor obviously
that will improve the projections and
decrease the death toll she is visibly
mad that more people haven't died which
in her mind means everything we've been
doing was pointless
and this is the anti-vaxxer conundrum
anti-vaxxers will often say measles
vaccine measles is so rare we don't need
a vaccine the reason measles is rare is
because we've had a good vaccine for a
long time now if we didn't have it more
people would get measles having it makes
people think we don't really need it
anti-vaxxers seem not to understand this
or at least pretend not to
lots of coronavirus contrarians as they
are sometimes called appear not to
understand that we bend the curve the
curve doesn't have unlimited power
it is not omnipotent we shape it by what
we do we should be glad we had more
resources deployed than necessary and
this is why the health care system needs
to be outside of the for-profit system
in the for-profit system being proactive
and being ahead of things being prepared
is not rewarded it actually doesn't even
fit with healthcare as a for-profit
entity in the mind of someone like Laura
Ingraham a hospital ship that didn't end
up being used or ventilators that we
didn't end up needing that's a sign of
failure because if you consider profit
the primary goal of the healthcare
system it has failed it deployed
resources that weren't actually needed
it's a waste of money now if you believe
that the health care systems primary
goal is to keep people healthy then when
you hear hey you know what we were able
to get more ventilators than most states
needed not all but most states needed or
we had a ship that ended up only being
used a tiny bit you're happy about that
because the goal is taking care of
people not making money so you say hey
wow we were more
paired than the level of disease we
ended up having that's a success when
you believe the primary goal is profit a
ship you don't need or ventilators you
don't use are considered signs of
failure that's why health care should be
outside of the for-profit model these
people at Fox News are sick
imagine being furious that we reduced
the death toll many so-called religious
believers refused to just follow the
direction of the federal and state
governments medical experts and public
health experts yesterday and they filled
churches on what was Easter 2020 one
place where this was particularly
prevalent was the state of Kentucky and
the governor Andy Beshear a democratic
Kentucky governor important detail here
since it almost went the other way
Andy Beshear said if you go to church on
Easter you will have to quarantine for
14 days to prevent the church from
becoming the Nexus of one of these super
spreader events and it was announced
that police would be at churches
recording license plate numbers they
would be sending out potentially sending
out misdemeanor violation orders
violation of orders issued by state
health officials and would be forced to
self quarantine for 14 days now of
course folks like Republican Senator
Rand Paul don't like it who cares what
Rand Paul thinks he took a test for the
virus and then went to the Senate gym
while the test was being processed
ultimately coming out positive for
coronavirus so clearly Rand Paul is not
the person we should be listening to
this we have video of the parking lot
and as you can see if you're watching a
full parking lot filled with people and
cars just like nothing is going on
Kentucky State Police did show up and
put notices like this one on people's
cars saying that the cars presence in
the parking lot indicates the occupants
are at a mass gathering which is
currently banned for public health
reasons they are at risk of contracting
coronavirus and they are to self
quarantine for 14 days here is video of
police officers walking around placing
the notices on vehicles and of course
even media people at the church covering
this insanity ended up with those same
notices on
aircars saying they need it to self
quarantine so do i love this no do I
want State Police having to do this of
course not public officials
health officials police officials
everyone's desperate so what do you do
when people believe going to church
protects them from coronavirus and you
immediately have all sorts of people
talking about this is authoritarian this
is a nightmare this is like martial law
people aren't allowed to pray and all of
this different stuff come on guys
come on can't you for a second put aside
that ideology and realize we none of us
like this but we've got to work together
we're in this together and forcing
police to have to do stuff like this out
of desperation is what's wrong
we have people who either don't care or
don't believe it or can't understand
what it is that is going on remember the
blood of Jesus lady this is a woman who
was interviewed leaving her church in
Ohio it was maybe last week or the week
before remember what she had to say
driving out of this Ohio parking lot is
a woman who just attended a church
service with dozens of other people
including children can I ask you about
your decision to go to church to be
inside that building I wouldn't be
anywhere else aren't you concerned you
could in fact other people if you get
sick inside I'm covered in Jesus blood
I'm covered in Jesus all of these people
go to this church but you're going to be
in places I can't the grocery store
every day I'm in Walmart thank you very
much
that is weaponized malignant ignorant
what do you do with that and of course
the police I mean you know if you hand
out these mandatory quarantine things to
thousands of churchgoers the police
don't even have the resources to
actually verify that all of those people
are self quarantine
they just don't so it's not only Trump
that is preventing us from dealing with
this as expeditiously and efficiently as
possible it's also these folks I saw
video from vancouver over the weekend of
so-called libertarians
protesting the lockdown by gathering on
the streets we're fighting the virus but
meanwhile they are fighting what they
say are you know authoritarian tactics
to keep them home some go even further
saying there's a consider a conspiracy
to hurt the economy on purpose merely to
remove Donald Trump so we're fighting
the virus which spreads virally we're
also fighting disinformation and
conspiracies and bad and/or ignorant
people all of whom seem to be viral
virally spreading their disinformation
as well
we now heard from dr. pouchy if we had
started earlier and taken this more
seriously and had a concerted lockdown
effort we would be much better off than
we are today
this is the type of stuff that I'm
talking about this segment is going to
be very depressing to many people in the
audience and I do apologize for that but
it has to be reported because it's so
troubling and atrocious the president
still doesn't understand viruses at some
general level remember that early in the
entire coronavirus pandemic we learned
from Trump's statements that he doesn't
really understand vaccines there were
signs that he didn't really understand
the concept of virus versus bacteria he
didn't understand the concept of
contagion or a viral spread or
exponential growth or herd immunity or
the concept of per capita or any of it
but by now we would at least hope that
he sort of understands the concept of a
virus but he still doesn't this is a
clip from his press briefing on Friday
now after we listen to it and watch it
we'll put up a transcript of it on the
screen because it is actually so
weaponized that you need to see it in
writing to fully grasp it here is Trump
talking about the germ is a genius and
it has figured out how not to be hurt by
antibiotics which of course antibiotics
are for bacteria not for viruses take a
look at this brilliant enemy they
develop drugs like the antibiotics you
see it antibiotics used to solve every
problem now one of the biggest problems
the world has
is the germ has gotten so brilliant that
the antibiotic can't keep up with it and
they're constantly trying to come up
with a new people go to a hospital and
they catch they go for a heart operation
that's no problem but they end up dying
from from problems you know the problems
I'm talking about there's a whole genius
to it
we're fighting not only is it hidden but
it's very smart okay it's invisible and
it's hidden but it's it's very smart and
you see that in a case like a denver but
you know I think we're doing well and
and there on Denver antibiotics used to
solve every problem he says until the
germ got brilliant and now can avoid it
except of course corona virus is a virus
you don't treat a virus with antibiotics
now let's look at some of this in
writing because it's actually really
really crazy look at what Donald Trump
says this is a very brilliant enemy you
know it's a brilliant enemy they develop
drugs like antibiotics you see it
antibiotics used to solve every problem
now one of the biggest problems the
world has is the germ has gotten so
brilliant that the antibiotic can't keep
up with it and they're constantly trying
to come up with a new people go to a
hospital and they catch they go for a
heart operation that's no problem
but they end up dying from from problems
you know the problems I'm talking about
there's a whole genius to it we're
fighting not only is it hidden but it's
very smart okay it's invisible and it's
hidden but it's it's very smart and you
see that in a case like Denver now there
are some defenders of Trump that are
arguing Trump is actually very astutely
talking about the problem of antibiotic
resistance is there any evidence that
suggests Trump ant understands
antibiotic resistance maybe what front
meant is that the genius of the germ is
that it chose to be a virus instead of a
bacteria so that antibiotics wouldn't
work against it is that something he has
the nuclear codes folks he has nuclear
launch codes
and he thinks a virus is a genius and
that it's not affected by antibiotics as
part of that genius this reminds me of
what might be Donald Trump's other big
crazy unintelligible rant about Uncle
John Trump and nuclear weapons there are
many highlights or lowlights but the
genius germ rant reminded me of the
Uncle John Trump rant which was this one
remember it know what wrecks me look
having nuclear my uncle was a great
professor and scientist and engineer dr.
John Trump at MIT good good genes very
good genes okay very smart the Wharton
School of Finance very good very smart
you know if you're a conservative
Republican if I were a liberal if like
okay if I ran as a liberal Democrat they
would say I'm one of the smartest people
that we're in the world true but when
you're a conservative Republican they
try or do they do a number that's why I
always sort of went to Wharton was a
good student went there went there did
this built before yet i have to give my
like credentials all the time because
we're a little disadvantaged but you
look at the nuclear deal the thing that
really bothers me it would have been so
easy and it's not as important as these
lives are nuclear is so powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power and that was 35
years ago he would explain the power of
what's going to happen and he was right
who would have thought but when you look
at what's going on with the four
prisoners now used to be three now it's
four but when it was three and even now
I would have said it's all in the
messenger fellas and it is fellas
because you know they don't they haven't
figured that the women are smarter right
now than the men so not only is that
insane to the degree that it rivals
Trump's more recent genius germ rant
note also how much more articulate Trump
is in that segment from just a few years
ago the decline in Trump's speech
capacity becomes even more clear when
you look even just a few years ago never
mind ten or fifteen years ago we are
really truly acutely screwed here guys